then doorbell fun dear sir I'm a
physician and I was wondering if
Florence can revolutionize medicine in
terms of drug delivery systems by its
unique properties my other passion is
sports and I wonder if this can be used
to make lighter records
well c60 I think if it is used in the
near future in medical applications
there will be two reasons and one will
be the fact that it is a very good free
radical scavenger so in systems where
free radicals are not good for in the
medical and the body I think it could be
useful there too to tie them up but the
one that looks likely to be most
interesting it hasn't been really solved
will be the fact that c60 is a cage and
it can trap atoms inside physically
though they're in they're not chemically
but physically so if they're inside the
cage then they're separated and save
their toxic such as radioactive atoms
and elements which may be toxic chemical
in the body you could put them inside
the cage and they would put probably
hydroxyl groups around which would or
some groups to make sure that the c60
wasn't toxic but and the atom on the
inside could be probably use that as a
radiation chemo radiation therapy and if
you tagged the outside of c60 with a
recognition mighty you could probably
tag it on to the place where the cancer
was and that seems to be probably one of
the most likely future applications of
of c60 in the medical area as far as the
rackets are concerned well I've often
said that if we can make this bundle of
nanotubes wouldn't be c60 particularly
but if we can make the bundle of
nanotubes that I suggesting 10 to the 15
about a meter long you would have an
incredibly strong
Tyrael but maybe if I could make it I
might be able to be Roger Federer on
that dowel with it but they may we'll
certainly be able to make materials with
superior tensile properties and very
light as well it would be definitely be
stronger than all rackets that have been
made up to now and significantly lighter
the problem of course in tennis is that
there's also a momentum effect so a
lighter racquet is not always all you
need you need some momentum in the head
of the racket so we'll see but it's on
the cards using nanotubes in future
composite materials but in this
paradigm-shifting mature where they're
all stuck together and you have the
coordinated structure and properties of
the whole thing that will be interesting